a championship bracket we have with us a
beg him from mizzou and with her coach
kristen carrillo begging first of all
congratulations welcome back to studio
how does it feel now that you finally
moved on to round number two
it still feels a little bit weird i feel
like i have to play couple of like more
games so maybe it will be all right
after still kind of weird i don't know
tell us a little bit about those last
few moments because we were confused
with the move bishop to e5 the last move
that you made
that repeats the position three times
did you ask for the repetition she did
she saw that after knight d7 it's a draw
but i i saw the like uh position and and
i thought oh probably it's a repetition
but i really didn't want to make a draw
if she moves something else my position
is better if she's gonna play knight d7
and she wants to draw i thought she's
gonna just declare it so i really didn't
wanna end the game but
from a coach's perspective
we're going to be talking about this
i knew that
i thought no i made a move then i
like wrote the mu and i was like oh [ __ ]
it's just like reputation three times
repetition yeah but you have to uh
to not make the moves exactly
and we'll talk but
let's go through the game let's go
through the game really quickly um
were she was she surprised in the
opening
i think she didn't expect me to play
this d4 c4 lines and she tried to
put me into position that i don't know i
guess that's why a6 was played i'm not
sure about my reaction but
i i just thought this position
should be fine for me
indeed it
worked out very doesn't make a lot of
sense after i take on d5
yeah the inclusion of both a6 and c6 is
a lost tempo in fact yeah and
surprisingly i remembered some things
that i uh like analyzed a couple years
ago like h3 this position should be
completely fine for white
so
well everything you did
had uh and actually the seal of approval
95 was uh novelty
to this moment after this point uh there
was a game between volkov and tufigy
actually rook d1 is not uh rookie right
yes
no ruckdive i shouldn't play rook 81
instead of i have to play rook e1
immediately that's how she has to go to
c5
uh
you want position yeah if you had this
position again probably you would like
to play the move rookie i'm not gonna
tell you
please tell me
maybe i'm wrong but now she cannot play
queen eat salmon because there's a v4
yeah if war you're right it feels better
for me and then i was a little bit
disappointed after r8d1
and
i thought i'm not pressing as much as i
would press after rook f you want to be
honest and now she wants to drop her to
e4 and i didn't want to play uh
knight d2 because of c5
now black has
some counterpoint maybe b3
i don't know and you didn't want to play
rook e1 because of knight e4 yeah yeah
clear i thought i should just try not to
change the structure
so
so 95 just holding
and here you well uh
you're right that you could play on if
you like with moves like rookie one but
winning the match and moving on is a
good thing big yeah i
hope gonna
like make a draw and try to play bishop
e6 or bishop d7 which would be better
for me but she didn't
well you're moving on to round number
two and uh tomorrow it seems from the
looks of this game between crush and ryu
yang that you're probably going to be
facing irena crush the eight-time
national champion you have some
experience with her but you never faced
her in a match situation how are you
going to approach that i don't know i
will ask my court
i'll have to think about it
well good luck uh tomorrow thank you
very much thank you thank you
well what a fighter i like the spirit
i'm better i don't want her to make a
draw so i'll give her the chance and
play on